[Music]
an elaborate lie news submitted by Joe's
hair again this thing is out of control
I swear I'm going for the mad scientist
look it's a pompadour now too much now
it's a bum beador like the middle our
article uh-huh a man is sentenced to
jail with six felonies for practicing
architecture without a license for
nearly a decade
Oh [ __ ] dairy you [ __ ] criminal how
dare you build that skyscraper without a
license why did the city approving
[ __ ] idiot that looked at the plans
it goes that's right this is a piece of
paper with crayons
good job famous architect Oh Paul Newman
sounds like an architecture name Newman
no the same Phil yeah I know but what's
amazing to music you know only that
reference but there's a very famous man
named but then I forgot if that was
really in any ways they're inside
Seinfeld connection you guys had I don't
know we can't talk about on camera
anyway they respond Newman's forty nine
years old he's a respected figure or was
a respected figure in the construction
industry in New York he was a draftsman
a graphic designer and an architect he
lived with his wife and two sons in the
home that he designed himself also
taught artist he also coached Little
League football and baseball but his
life was built on a lie
why because he wasn't an architect he
was the S&M bondage guy no it's from the
headline he never actually got his
license he just cut corners didn't even
have a license tell me how to license at
least tutitu to coach Little League
that's what I want to know the important
stuff cuz you're teaching kids like a
bunch of [ __ ] they don't like if you
don't hole but what all throughout livee
bullshit's everything all right guys
when you hit the ball you run that way
dude that's what I want to do to my kids
so bad it's like right now you're
watching the sport of soccer it's like
baseball and so that way they just get
[ __ ] rolled through school just
completely wrecked yeah he's like okay
he's like hey teacher can I can I use
the bathroom and it's like sure it is
like okay cool I'm just gonna go out the
window and then did you ba what though
yeah taught em all wind all doors or
windows it's pretty good right if I
commit to that [ __ ] and I'm always like
okay I'm walking out the window and
every time you get caught it's like oh
that's how we say it in the East Coast
so fast for 20 years hey Steve what's it
like time you can't ever talk to you as
a rejoinder who's the baddest
[ __ ] that ever lived my my son
because he got bullied everywhere and he
is still alive it's like that Johnny
Cash song you named in a suit it's just
make him a tough son of a [ __ ] yes
that's some gangster [ __ ] you know the
old days like it's kind of like they
were even hardcore than us cuz the the
older generation look at us like like
pansies we used to [ __ ] kill people
one more - whatever right and if they
had Johnny Cash but all the music back
then was so like yeah cuz life was so
tough man or something it's like the
[ __ ] monkeys and [ __ ] it's like it
has to be way more positive to make up
for so much sadness but it's so funny
and then you have his lyrics it's like I
shot a guy but it's like it's it's still
like dude
yeah nowadays [ __ ] is so dark dude like
a law-and-order episode was like I was
raped and then I was like assaulted and
then I was raped in the car by a cop
it's always like god everything's so
[ __ ] dark where life is easier than
ever for everyone the percent iced tea
is trying to figure it out for some
reason right he's like you guys are too
happy let me just bring you down a
little bit so I started off as a
draftsman in the 90s working for an
architecture firm and Boston he was
really talented that his hand-drawn
renderings of projects were amazing this
is before computers bosses were saying
that he was studying to be an architect
that it was his dream to become an
architect and leaving that company in
2005 and then co-workers never heard
from him after that then he started his
own company in 2010 and he was getting
big jobs as an architect even though he
never actually went to school to get his
license and so the architecture license
requires years of work experience formal
education and a lengthy examination
which is a very hard test apparently and
it lasts for days so here you just cut
corners skip getting the license and
just started doing work as an architect
all I hear is that this guy's a genius I
mean yeah because I was thinking about
the whole safety and all that stuff but
there's enough checks and balances to
where like usually when you build a
structure the government will have
inspectors that goes well and then they
will look at your blueprints and all
that [ __ ] and be like well that's not
safe that's not safe they'll let you
know you got to redo that well I mean
the architect is pretty high up in the
whole building process so I feel like
maybe the inspectors might not even
realize like once the building's already
yeah like there's got to be a reason why
it's illegal necessarily I mean we have
a lot of stupid laws to but it's like
accountants lawyers everyone has like a
a like body that they report to like you
have to take the CPA license to
practices you know what I mean like you
have to take the bar exam to be a lawyer
like you can't just willy-nilly be a
professional well I'm taking a genius
because he's been doing it and he great
he had a huge professional career
already yeah I mean he was talented it
seems like that's all I'm saying well I
haven't seen one of his buildings yet so
I'm not gonna save time today oh yeah
a lot of work I did the first ever wood
skyscrapers wonderful sand wood made out
of toothpicks yeah yeah well you even
made a fake rubber stamp and use it to
sign off on over a thousand building
plans and inspection that's how he did
yeah yeah have to get approved doing
something fraudulent no he's away the
rules it's like no right
Oh see when they're they're doing crime
it's it's on that level it's fraud my
color I don't know I feel like probably
maybe I mean you're not I feel like
white-collar crime is anything not
involving like guns it's kind of like
paperwork and you know not Breno not
following all the rules I don't know
that's pretty close to cashing fake
checks that's what they do so then at
one point he took a job in Florida for a
project to construct an add-on for a
church but he failed to complete that
job so the bishop he ended up filing a
complaint with the New York Board of
architecture like who is this guy yeah
the board find Paul for practicing
architecture without a license and then
his whole company started to be
investigated he started to remove any
reference from reference to Architecture
in his marketing and then replace it
with design services and then in 2016
the New York State Attorney General
indicted him and he was arrested in
April of 2017 he pleaded guilty to six
felonies including grand larceny forgery
fraud and unlicensed practice of
architecture how long ago about two to
seven years and also he has to pay a
hundred and fifteen thousand dollars in
restitution
he made a lot more than that wait that's
a felony it's a six six felonies two to
seven years right that's a felony
right that's a lot of felonies brah yeah
I like to maybe two years yeah it's
pretty tight yes cuz it's the type of
crime it's not like violent crime maybe
what do you mean he's making money off
people and not even having a license
it's not violent crime
well your frauding they you didn't say
that [ __ ] during the hot dog one man
races best wait so why call a crime
usually you don't do go to the same
prison this is a federal yeah state is
two years minimum right Wow even if you
go to yeah even if you do nonviolent
crime but if it's on a high higher level
I think you might just go to regular
jail - he's not gonna survive dude
either or either are you well you might
come out of bed ass I don't know he's a
resourceful [ __ ] [ __ ] maybe he'll
study for his exams
oh right Oh 116 jeez that's it but I
appreciate you mean a lot more yeah it's
probably bad from even getting a license
now do you think any of his buildings
are crumbling good what if he's like
super talented he's just lazy to get the
license cuz I'm kind of like that I
always look for other ways what's the
what's the least illegal way for me to
do something leave would be that's
illegal shortcuts are for smart people
that's kind of true like there's always
red tape and stuff like signing up
positions that's where other people not
from me you know dude how many lawyers
passed the bar you know I'm saying cuz I
feel like the system cheated me I had
straight A's 4.0 for a whole tire and
then after that I kept going and I was
like I need a good GPA to get a job all
this stuff nobody gives a [ __ ] about
your GPA you work so hard at college
it's like why the GPA doesn't matter I
couldn't [ __ ] basket to see if as
long as I got a degree it was a degree
I am I [ __ ] myself over so I was like
from then on I'm going back to being a
criminal oh I learned my lessons it's
about who you know and who you blow
that's what it is
and if you're partying and you're [ __ ]
just open the gate you're coming through
it if you want an engineering job just
got to be Indian you're good mom
everybody wants an Indian thank you
mostly I mean if you're Native American
you can go anywhere and do anything you
know I was in Oklahoma there's actually
a lot of Native Americans in Oklahoma
Oklahoma the fee met I didn't know was
they look like 99% white people
we were at the casino and then I was
like huh Indian casino who knows like
we're love Indians and in like the
viewer I looked like the [ __ ] 1800s
version
no I mean I don't expect a [ __ ] like
the the chief chief running ball or
whatever with the [ __ ] big headdress
I mean like we have Indian casinos here
in casino I mean California they look
like Mexicans they look like we're like
they're brown you know but over there I
was like oh cool like this is ending
sinneth and there's a lot of natives
here huh and then like so I was talking
to the dealer I'm like so so where are
they and he was like you're looking at
him
your ass is percentage those like you
know how much Indian arguments the thing
it's like it's it's a really small
percentage but they still have like an
ID and all that stuff I forgot what it
takes it's like it's like 2% or some
[ __ ] and all the type of Native American
you are if you're like Inuit it doesn't
count there's a certain tribe yeah
certain tribes like Cherokee whatever I
hope you guys enjoyed this video
for more please subscribe to our Channel
and you can check out the last video
right here
[Music]